Welcome back, dear viewers of SCP Explained.
We hope you’ve been keeping well, and we
also hope that your health insurance covers
blown minds, because today, we’re using
our trademark Anom-O-Tron 6000 to pit an anomalous
legend against another Marvel legend.
That’s right - it’s SCP-682 Vs Dr. Michael
Morbius, of the 2022 cinematic masterpiece,
Morbius.
Of course, there is one issue that we should
share with you before we begin: We haven’t
actually seen Morbius.
However, here’s the wonderful thing - Statistically,
you haven’t either.
In fact, we tried to get the Anom-O-Tron 6000
to process Morbius as raw data for the simulation,
but our antivirus software kept stopping it.
Intriguing.
So instead, we simply hit “Randomize Traits”
on the Anom-O-Tron, so it’s free to use
advanced AI to conceive what Morbius is like,
and what his abilities probably are.
And as far as you or I know, it might even
be correct.
So let’s get this show on the road, and
see if the Hard to Destroy Reptile could hold
its own at cinema’s most tragically memed-upon
superhero.
Prepare for perhaps the most absurd and ridiculous
video we’ve ever released on here.
In other words, it’s Morbin Time.
It began, as many bizarre SCP Foundation stories
do, with SCP-682 cracking the glass of its
acid tank and preparing to spill chaos and
terror out into Site 19.
For most people, even seeing actual footage
of this would be a life-defining traumatic
incident.
For most seasoned Foundation researchers,
it was just another Sunday.
When 682 busted through the nearest wall like
a psychopathic, reptilian Kool Aid man, while
guards engaged in the futile task of trying
to subdue it with small arms fire, the senior
researchers languidly made their way to the
nearest secure panic room and hunkered down.
As was standard protocol for SCP-682 escapes,
all available Mobile Task Force units would
be dispatched, single-mindedly focused on
cutting the lizard back down to size.
But the problem was, this wasn’t just any
other Sunday, it was Super Bowl Sunday - and
seeing as most Mobile Task Force operatives
are incredibly tough and manly, they generally
love football, and promised they’d definitely
come and take down 682...
As soon as the game was over.
This would be one thing if SCP-682 was content
to just terrorize the usual denizens of Site
19 today, but no.
It’d been a while since the Hard to Destroy
Reptile had tasted civilian flesh, and he
intended to rectify that tout suite.
In a state of murderous fury, 682 barged through
wall after all with the effort that a normal
human being might walk through rice paper.
Soon enough, it was free from the drab gray
walls of the containment site, and feeling
the sun on its scales once more.
Such a lovely day out, with the distant sound
of people laughing and chatting, and children
playing happily with their pets. 682, predictably,
found this disgusting, and resolved to destroy
them all.
And with all those Mobile Task Force operatives
swigging beer, eating peanuts, and giggling
at amusing celebrity cameos in Super Bowl
half time ads, there would be nobody who would
stop 682 from completing its dastardly task.
Except, of course, one man: Dr. Michael Morbius.
While 682 was escaping, Morbius was sitting
on the deck of his private yacht, drinking
a martini glass full of two percent milk - because
Morbius understands the importance of having
healthy bones.
He was listening to a fascinating podcast
about the curative powers of beef jerky when,
high above, the SCP Foundation activated the
Morb Signal: A Batman-esque light shining
up in the sky in the shape of a clown.
This was bad.
Morbius paused his podcast and prepared himself,
finishing the last of his milk and washing
out the glass so it didn’t get smelly.
He raised his arm and summoned the Morb Orb
- a glowing red ball that seems to be the
source of his powers, according to a number
of internet memes.
He clutched the Orb, feeling its power flow
through him, as he made a small prayer to
his guardian deity, the late David Bowie.
And with that, he took flight, twin jets of
fire blasting out of his shoes like rocket
ships.
He could only hope that he’d be able to
intercept SCP-682 before it was too late.
Meanwhile, SCP-682 was indulging in one of
his favorite hobbies: Just killing lots of
people.
He’d invaded the American city of San Fran
Angeles, New York, which is known for being
the biggest population of people within the
proximity of Site 19.
682 was truly rampaging - He knocked the ice
cream cones out of children’s hands, causing
them to weep profusely.
He literally kicked dogs.
And he also murdered a number of adults with
his vicious fangs and claws.
The local police attempted to stop him, but
they were hopelessly outmatched.
They attempted to cuff the monster several
times, only to find out that by the time they
were half way through trying to read the beast
its Miranda Rights, it would break free and
rampage yet again.
All in all, SCP-682 was having a grand old
time, and was delighted that nobody was coming
to stop its rampage of utter devastation.
It seemed almost as though the rampage would
never end, until a dark shadow fell over the
ravenous reptilian monster.
It turned up its head to see a new foe floating
above it.
Was it a bird?
Was it a plane?
No, it was Dr. Michael Morbius, of course,
wielding his trademark flaming trident of
justice.
“Another lamb to the slaughter,” 682 growled.
“Are you ready to meet your end?”
Morbius laughed and shook his head.
“I don’t know what you are, you scaly
monster, but for hurting all these innocent
people, you’re about to get morbed on!”
And with that, he threw his flaming trident
at the reptile, striking brave and true - But
it wasn’t enough.
682 had developed incredibly strong reflexes
after years of the Foundation’s attempts
on its life, so Morbius would need to try
a lot harder than just using his classic,
beloved trident to end this fight.
Even then, before Morbius had a chance to
think up another method of attack, 682 had
adapted and switched to the offensive.
Two great, dragon-like leathery wings unfurled
on the monster’s back, and it took air,
lunging towards Morbius with fangs borne and
claws at the ready.
Before Morbius knew it, the creature’s jaws
were ready to close around his head.
Thankfully, at this moment, another one of
Morbius’ classic superpowers comes into
play: His short-range teleportation abilities.
In a moment of reflex that would impress 682,
Morbius teleported out of the monster’s
path, remanifesting instantly, floating a
few feet away.
682 growled in irritation.
“Of course it would never be so easy,”
it said.
“The Foundation always ends one of its freaks
to distract me.
You may think you’re strong, but really,
you’re just another puppet.”
“I’ve never heard of this Foundation,”
Morbius quipped back.
“And I’m not your standard hero, either.
I really blur the line between Hero and villain
entirely.
In fact—“
Before Morbius could finish explaining what
a complex character he was, 682 flew after
him again.
This time, however, Morbius was ready.
He lifted up his arms and unleashed another
one of his patented attacks: Opening up human
mouths in the palm of his hands, which unleash
miniature yet still extremely powerful air
to air missiles.
The missies blasted out and struck 682, causing
an impressive explosion, but 682 was well-versed
in explosions.
It kept flying after Morbius.
He needed to get out of here, fast, or he’d
become a lizard’s lunch.
Morbius turned and flew in the opposite direction,
the Hard to Destroy Reptile hot on his heels.
The first step, of course, would be to get
away from populated areas to limit collateral
damage.
No matter what happened, Morbius refused to
let this mysterious entity harm more people.
“You can’t run forever!”
682 growled.
“Your wretched life will be brought to a
slow and painful end, stranger!”
They were passing over the water now, flying
at quantum speeds, watching the Pacific Ocean
whizz past beneath them.
That’s when Morbius noticed it, and had
an epiphany: A volcano!
And by the looks of the smoke rising above
it, an active one, too!
Morbius had a plan now, but to execute it,
he’d need perfect speed and timing.
He stopped in mid air as the beast flew towards
him - But moments before 682 could make contact,
Morbius grabbed it, executing a perfect mid-air
suplex, and tossing the roaring beast directly
down into the volcano below.
For any other monster, that would be the end
of it.
But for 682, a double, triple, or even quadruple
tap was often required to reliably incapacitate
it.
Morbius’ work was not done.
He flew down towards the volcano, ready to
engage in the next hectic stage of battle.
“Bet you’re not feeling so cocky now,
you nasty reptile!”
Morbius yelled.
But the reptile in question was too busy flailing
around in impossibly hot magma to reply at
the time, such is the way when falling into
an active volcano.
SCP-682, burnt and charred, but alive, began
to crawl from the top of the volcano, wheezing
out smoke and ash.
How could such a strange, confusing creature
have been such a formidable opponent?
No matter, it will destroy this “Morbius”,
it might just take a little longer than expected.
Little did the unfortunate reptile know, Morbius
was preparing his next weapon, perfect for
immobilizing this ornery monster: An 8-ball
in a gym sock, forming a kind of dangerous
makeshift flail.
It was the kind of lethal improvised weapon
that would strike fear into even one of the
strongest enemy combatants.
And now, SCP-682 would learn to fear its power.
As the flame-broiled reptile began to stand,
perhaps preparing to adapt to its latest set
of injuries, Morbius began relentlessly beating
the Hard to Destroy Reptile with the 8-ball
sock, dazing it with repeated brutal strikes
that seemed to never stop.
Morbius had learned this technique from years
of being involved in vicious bar fights, normally
caused by him cheating at darts.
“This can stop any time you want,” Morbius
yelled.
“You just need to stop getting back up.”
Initially, 682 wanted to remain defiant, but
even it couldn’t deny that being struck
again and again by the 8-ball sock was actually
extremely painful.
Was it really worth the fight?
After performing some quick mental calculations,
SCP-682 determined that no, it probably wasn’t.
Time to throw in the towel.
“Okay, Okay,” 682 said, mostly annoyed
at this point.
“I’ll stop rampaging.
Honestly, you just took all the fun out of
it.”
682 just sighed and laid on the ground, exhausted,
slowly regenerating from its injuries.
Morbius smiled, content with his victory.
Who knows how many people he’d saved by
luring this creature away from a population
center?
By this point, the Super Bowl was over, and
the legions of Mobile Task Force operatives,
who technically should have done this hours
ago, finally decided to suit up and take care
of business.
It didn’t take long for black tactical helicopters
full of Foundation soldiers managed to triangulate
the location of the volcano where the end
of 682 and Morbius’ epic battle had taken
place.
It wasn’t long after that that there were
copious Foundation boots on the ground.
The story, of course, has a happy ending:
Mobile Task Force Agents successfully recaptured
SCP-682 and returned it to the containment
cell in Site 19.
And in the process of recovery, they mistook
Dr. Michael Morbius for the actor Jared Leto,
and shot him roughly 30 times in the chest
with armor-piercing rounds, killing him instantly.
Want an anomaly of your own?
Check out www.scpswag.com for high-quality
SCP merch!
Now go and check out “SCP-096 Vs Siren Head”
and “SCP-076 ABLE VS CHAINSAW MAN...
WHO HAS THE MOST LETHAL WEAPON?”
for more wild Vs battles!